mais c'est déjà la vie c'est tout con
quand est astucieux peine
vous faites tous plus y est le plus
sérieux à jouer et le devenir amis
bonjour février bonjour tout cas encore
mais qu'est ce que tu fais avec sa masse
bec à j 1 cm bastien mais pour quoi
faire
bah on m'a dit de mesurer mes paroles ah
oui alors vous n'aurez pas ma mesure il
bec abattant j'étais monsieur j'ai
l'impression vie métro moi je vais te
mesurer le bec tout de suite je vais te
dire ça parce qu'effectivement comme des
méfaits avec énorme ça va vous chercher
tout de même un truc comme ça
oh oui ça fait dans les quinze
centimètres jolie bec et un beau père a
une jolie bague sertie bobines et bons
becs et que de paris quand tu as dit
l'être c'est évident on joue maintenant
à vie nous allons jouer au jeu de la
géographie je connaissais le principe
c'est très simple tout concourt à
préparer pour vous trois éléments qui
vont vous permettre de découvrir le nom
d'un pays
vous avez la carte géographique du pays
vous avez attrapé le drapeau et vous
avez également bonjour dans la langue du
pays en question et tout ça est derrière
le crocus c'est un crocus et un mois
pour moi c'est un concurent soit 58 un
très bon cru que tu cela mais commençons
par la carte à vu de rieux à 8
j'arrive pas du tout à 6 à 6 - même je
me suis attraper avec ça tu vois c'est
vrai oui je n'avais pas ce que c'était
aussi ça ça me paraît relativement
facile
vous voyez que il ya beaucoup de côtes
et que la capitale de ce pays se trouve
ici bon sur la côte sur la côte oui sur
la côte
nous avons maintenant le drapeau du pays
je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous sont
très forts en géographie et que vous
n'aurez pas de difficultés à reconnaître
ce pays je précise pour ceux qui n'ont
pas la couleur que ce drapeau a ses
caractéristiques d'ailleurs des drapeaux
des pays de la région et blanc alors la
couleur sert à rien si c'est vraiment là
mais là là c'est important ça c'est ces
bleus sa cible
croix et bleu sur fond blanc à fait
raison alors maintenant comment dit-on
bon jury alors si là que je comprends et
ça va pas être facile paris là tu sais
si tu vas voir si tiens regarde je m'en
doutais que ça va pas être comme eux
alors tu veux te le dit s'il te plaît
vas-y winter à wingles à tapas y vas tu
dis comme ça trois roues bentayou même
tapas y va alors curieusement c'est une
langue très spécial qui n'a pas de
rapport avec les langues des pays
voisins
d'ailleurs je vais te dire une chose
mais on dit ouah mais mi-temps 6-6 le
matin et pas y va si c'est dans la
journée tu crois ça ah oui c'est ça
c'est possible je ne suis pas très calé
dans cette langue
alors mes enfants vous allez découvrir
de quoi il s'agit vous savez vous
surpris maintenant bien le pays regardez
ça c'est la finlande
je vais bien j'ai bien trouvé un c'est
la finlande est la capitale de la
finlande c'est health inc y voilà et ça
c'est du finnois qui est une langue très
très difficile et très paris non loin du
finnois pr nous finnois le finnois le
rhino toi ça suffit non sinon je vais
dans le jardin en pente finaux une moto
tu t'en vas déjà je me lève tout ça oui
carrément ans je vais encore avoir peur
mais non produit on est jeune où êtes
vous on ira mieux
vous voilà pour l on est plus nerveuse
m'énerve tout de suite donné le point 8
com - comme un wiki que d'ici là bon
j'espère que les fabris ou alors voila
voila je arrive à
la vue l'escargot là dans le jardin la
coutume a semblé percevoir son ombre
mais j'en étais pas si oui espérons ne
pas vous y va où
oui nous y allons alors c'est le jeu du
point commun voilà rappelons brièvement
que tout cancan belles belles et pousse
moussu et incarne quelque chose ou
quelqu'un etc et nous devons découvrir
tous ensemble quel est le point commun
qu'ils ont entre alençon
alors moi à part ça je te le dis tout
facile baasiste écoute si tu possèdes
une voiture oui mais possède aussi voilà
ah bon ça déjà ça te met sur la voie non
je fais partie de toutes les voitures
hors bienvenue je suis pas indispensable
pour les faire marcher a pas du tout je
suis pas ni dans le moteur ni dans la
direction et dans l'éclairage non je ne
suis même pas dans les sièges n'est ni
dans la malle arrière
allez tu te demandes ce que je peux être
bah oui c'est pas ça et bien et c'est un
peu de rouler sans moi 1 et si tu
arrives à faire quelques kilomètres sans
faire arrêter par les gendarmes
et bah alors je te paye un sifflet à
siffler oui bah j'en aurais peut-être
besoin belbel c'est à toi
et bien moi vous me connaissez si vous
êtes gourmand et comme vous êtes tous
gourmand là je suis content que vous me
connaissez bien tous et tous assurent
que fabrice mais attention quand je dis
gour moi je ne parle pas des bonbons et
des gâteaux je parle uniquement les
chocolats ce chocolat c'est bien
enveloppé dans du papier de toutes les
couleurs je suis souvent très pur mais
j'accepte parfois pour votre plaisir mes
amis de me mélanger certaines petites
friandises comme des noisettes ont des
amants de la crème
je m'arrête j'en ai l'eau à la bouche
fabrice et bah ouais moi aussi mais je
te dire une chose c'est que je suis bien
embarrassée parce que pour l'instant je
ne sais pas du tout à aller jusqu'au
bout ce monsieur je sens que je vais te
faire plaisir oui oui oui parce que moi
vous me connaissez si vous vous
intéressez aux chemins de fer et je
crois que c'est ton copain fabrice on
m'a dit que talvera un circuit complet
extraordinaire avec des aiguillages des
passages à niveau des villes est dû
des tunnels des butoirs déclare etc etc
il y en a tellement nécessaire je ne
peux pas les citer tous ça mais celui
que je suis aujourd'hui est très très
important oui pour faciliter la
circulation de tous ces wagons et de
toutes ces locomotives pour les faire
passer d'une voix une autre très
facilement en leur faisant faire un
petit tour de manège tu vas à cette fois
ci je crois que j'en ai trop dit la fin
je crois que tu as trouvé non pas du
tout parce que je veux dire une chose
j'aime beaucoup de mal à me concentrer
je suis très distrait et alors là je
n'ai pas bien suivi aujourd'hui tu m'as
parlé d'une voix bas à faire passer
faire passer d'un accès pour lui
aujourd'hui on le sait l'aiguillage
c'est pour un cd un ryan aux municipales
aiguilles assez pour faire passer la
locomotive en lui faisant faire un petit
tour de manège sur une autre voie ah ah
il ne fait pas ces gens s'en va je ne
sais pas aujourd'hui je suis collé l'âge
que les élèves ou les inquiète
il s'appelait nous fait qu'est-ce que tu
étais toi tout con con hein qu'est ce
que tu étais à jeter une plaque
d'automobiles la villa qui se finira le
genre la lumière du ct non une plaque de
chocolat au lait au chocolat et toi pour
une plaque tournante mais j'en ai une
mais oui mais on ne peut pas toujours
gagner c'est normal
bravo vous avez gagné tous les trois à
vous
êtes vous avez certainement été plus
malin que moi aujourd'hui mais pour une
fois j'ai perdu ça arrive c'est comme ça
alors bell bell lui a préparé le jeu
mais les systèmes ans mais j'espère que
tu vas perdre aussi y'a pas de raison
aujourd'hui je veux tu perdes sur tous
les thèmes en bas je te remercie ce
gentil si si si mais c'est parce que je
t'aime que je te fais un petit peu de
mal de temps aux autres si je suis ici à
meerab à petit tout cas conclue mais
fabrice 1 c'est notre petit jeu alors tu
vas au tableau comme d'habitude bah oui
je vais essayer de te coller un
pansement ça a mal commencé pour moi
aujourd'hui
alors oui cette semaine un mot en neuf
lettres 9 l'état donc l'amendé par là on
commence par un homme alors ne reflète
donc tu fais cette petite reine comme
d'habitude voilà et alors la dernière et
voilà voilà
alors maintenant je t'écoute une fleur
non ce n'est pas une plage blanc tu une
quoi une plante non non c'est pas une
plants and animals
oui ah bah oui c'est un animal ni
toujours un animal alors à un petit
animal un petit un petit aquitanima d'un
petit animal qui courent oui ah oui là
quatre pattes et l'a14 petit bras louis
et coup il est mignon au éliminions
louis pardo et sa cellule mais moi oui
qu'est-ce que je crois que j toulouse
ah oui mais non sera bien rapide au
chocolat c'est moi qui joue perso à
jouer avec fabrice bible c'est tout de
même moins des gentils rapidos mal mais
enfin il avait dit que c'est mignon
ah oui c'est très mignon ah oui ah oui
mon petit animal avec un petit nez la
troisième les bruits c'est un ace
ah bah oui on sera une arme et avec un s
quand même soit par des ventes mais tout
de même
et oh avec un petit à petit tu penses à
musaraigne musaraigne voilà mais comme
en écriture musaraigne podium sur les
crimes et méhari bas comme ça se
prononce m us
ar et accent aigu gnl jaï alaï nous
regarde comment on écrit musaraigne
maladroit ait pu s à air à yves g n
comment voulez vous que je devine un bon
c'est qu'alors c'est comme à régner
alors si la reine comme araignée bon ben
je sais pas beaucoup de programmes
annoncent qu'ils auront un procès normal
règne c'est délicieux avec encore est ce
que tu sais que dans le midi
il ya une espèce minuscule c'est le plus
petit animal à quatre pattes de l'europe
et tiens toi bien
il pèse 2 g c'est pourquoi tu te rends
compte 2 g
c'est trompettiste fois que je suis fort
et là ça c'est bien
deux grands programmes oui deux graves
oui oui oui ça te plaît pas ça tout cas
ça fait rêver
si nous allions retrouver bell bell est
un jeu musical
vous êtes d'accord
qu'as tu appris ce piège là avec moi
la musique y côtoie charte abri oui mais
pour notre petite histoire en jeu celui
près j'espère que je vais te connu comme
dans notre point commun si le peuple ne
remue pas le couteau dans la plaie bon
tu sais que tu dois terminer les mots
que j'ai laissé inachevé par une note de
musique et que toutes ces notes quand
les reliera te permettront de chanter
sur un air très connu la petite histoire
que je vais te raconter
bon ok aujourd'hui je te raconte
l'histoire d'un drôle de bonhomme
d'abord c'est un monsieur qui a pas mal
de dos comme s'il allait il n'a pas mal
de dos s'il domicile hexadome ici
il a plusieurs maisons qui sont tout
aussi mal entretenues les unes que les
autres elles s'en vont en ruines
il a aussi des enfants qui ne valent pas
mieux que ces maisons
il a des garçons des filles enfin une
nombreuse famille me à mais alors fin je
vais te mettre fin à sa prévention
c'est parfait je peux aussi te dire que
ce monsieur est en général assez mal
habillé une étape du montât coquet sol
absolimmo sol a paru manquer oui il se
monsieur également des chiens qu'ils
utilisent pour la chasse au combat la
chasse aux la chasse aux poupin à la fin
aulas pas oui la chanson la poubelle
malheureusement ces chiens ne sont pas
très adroit je dirais même carrément
qu'ils sont mapping droit encore là
maladroit bravo bord et ce qui
n'étonnera pas non plus c'est que notre
personnage a aussi dit
ah j'adore le choc
il ne donne jamais à manger ce qui fait
que les chats sont maigres
perchée sur des grandes pattes on dirait
des écharpes la flèche alors là tu veux
que notre personnage est assez étrange
il est pas mal de bêtises mais faut lui
pardonner il faut le lui pardonner mais
les quoi lui par harry lui pardonner lui
pardonne il illustre est mal vue du
seuil sans mots qui n'en fait pas une
marque ni une maladie
aladdin fait oui tu relis les notes que
tu viennes placé alors nous avons mille
façons lala lala dollars oui ça je sais
ce que c'est oui c'est le cadet
rousselle exactement la saison et jouer
à deus à tort car c'est la loi mais non
qimni poutre d'état qui se partageront
faisait le début mois de musiciens daba
daba
quand tu entends pas absolument c'est la
mer aux sales pattes d'envié chanter
avec moi je gagne ou je n'ai pas gagné
wimbledon sa famille j'ai d'ailleurs je
ne veux pas y aller
outre mais vient chanter avec moi
j'arrive je t'avouerai peut-être que oui
effectivement à catane
l'état s'est déjà pas permis de la vie
majeur s'est désisté et g shock fait des
choses mais comme je ne nie pas de
minois livre on a fait attention les
cartes à gratter sans répit les yaks ça
me sens heureux paris c'est ma vie
les
m
mais non
j ai dit vouloir devenir amis